[Music]
hello everyone how are you all doing
today so last night I was watching the
Goblet of Fire which I normally do
sometimes as a bedtime sleeping aid to
get my mind off of all the Star Wars
content remember when Hagrid shows Harry
the hungarian horntail it made me think
how powerful the beast was and that led
to this video dragons can surely kill
men and women of any kind easily but
could it withstand the most powerful
spell
Avada Kedavra today let's discuss it
Avada Kedavra would kill any man or
woman or child unless of course in the
area's peculiar case in which he was
protected by love so it's simple someone
just has to love a dragon so much that
they protect it no I'm kidding so while
spells and curses work proficiently well
on humans and other species of similar
sizes extremely large creatures like
dragons trolls and other massive beasts
such as the acromantula that Harry
fought are a different story now here's
the thing with these massive beasts and
creatures spells on them are just like
humans trying to use an arrow to kill a
rhino in most cases it just won't work
especially if we're talking about a
dragon with dragon hide with their
scales and literal impenetrable skin
Avada Kedavra would most likely be
ineffective from one witch or wizard
against such a large beast however
multiple spell casters would surely
bring down the beast no question
regardless of where they aimed that said
for a single Witcher wizard to kill the
Beast
using Avada Kedavra it's my theory that
they would have to attack the weak point
such as the eye or perhaps even the
underbelly or perhaps a wound that was
already opened a vulnerable spot that
would cause severe damage to the Beast
regardless of spells being cast let
alone the most powerful of them all
Avada Kedavra now in fantastic beasts
were shown that Wizards care more for
animal conservation than many muggles
they in fact preserve man-eating dragons
they also don't really tell us about the
extinct species such as the dodo because
it keeps them aware regarding the
dangers of constantly killing animals
without reason and with that it
quite unlikely witches or wizards would
go around practicing Avada Kedavra
around such beasts and to top it all off
to be able to even use the spell one
must get within close range and by that
point while you're most likely charcoal
or eaten alive now another point in the
Goblet of Fire were also told in the
book that dragons are particularly
resistant to magic it doesn't say how
resistant but you can imagine the
context in which such a large and
magical creature would be able to
protect themselves from attacks by
medium ranked witches and wizards I'd
love it if we got a book in the future
that would conclude or give us some more
information on how powerful these beasts
were and how resistant to spells and
which spells they were resistant to in
conclusion it's my theory that they
would repel such an attack unless
several wizards gang up on it and
already have it weakened or if it's
attacked at its most vulnerable spot
like its eyes it would be cool if
dragons were completely resistant
towards any spell or curse such as Avada
Kedavra however that being the most
powerful one of them all it still would
penetrate at some point but there will
have to be many variable factors in
there I hope you enjoyed this video hit
like if you did and remember help will
always be given at Hogwarts to those who
deserve it
[Music]